in the East Room today a somber
president Trump reacting to yet another
school shooting unfortunately I have to
begin by expressing our sadness and
heartbreak over the deadly shooting at
Santa Fe High School in Texas this has
been going on too long in our country
too many years too many decades now we
grieve for the terrible loss of life and
send our support and love to everyone
affected by this absolutely horrific
attack in the wake of the last major
school shooting Marjory Stoneman Douglas
high in Florida President Trump held
meetings with victims families gun and
school safety groups he proposed several
safety reforms including arming
qualified teachers and school staff that
backed off a call to raise the minimum
age to buy a rifle from 18 to 21
today President Trump found himself
right back where he was the day of the
Parkland shooting my administration is
determined to do everything in our power
to protect our students secure our
schools and to keep weapons out of the
hands of those who pose a threat
everyone must work together at every
level of government to keep our children
safe the event in the East Room was to
highlight president Trump's support for
prison reform the president Trump also
used it to make a surprise announcement
introducing members of his cabinet the
president shocked his acting Secretary
of Veterans Affairs Robert Wilkins
secretary Wilkie who by the way has done
an incredible job at the VA and I'll be
informing him in a little while he
doesn't know this yet that we're going
to be putting his name up for nomination
to be Secretary of the Veterans
Administration
I'm sorry that I ruined the surprise
Wilkie who was serving as Undersecretary
of defense for personnel and readiness
before he became the acting VA secretary
has a deep military background having
served in both the Navy and Air Force
and at the Pentagon during the Bush 43
administration we also got a better idea
today of how President Trump will
prepare for a possible interview with
special counsel Robert Muller Rudy
Giuliani telling Fox News the prep
sessions will mirror debate prep during
the campaign some sessions may take
place after hours at the White House but
Giuliani prefers weekends at the
president's summer home in Bedminster
New Jersey Giuliani is also considering
bringing outside people into the process
including former New Jersey Governor
Chris Christie who also helped with
debate prep and Giuliani tells Fox News
that Robert Muller has significantly
narrowed the scope and number of
questions he would ask in an interview
Giuliani says the number of questions is
down to about 20 from 50 and the topics
have been narrowed down to questions
about Russia and the firing of James
Comey Giuliani tells Fox News he
believes that the special counsel Robert
Muller has shown that he is acting in
good faith by whittling down the
questions as to when the president might
start preparing Giuliani says likely not
until after the summit in South Korea
but if that summit for some reason is
cancelled then the president could start
getting ready sometime within the next
two to three weeks and a development
today in the Michael Cohen case an
attorney for Cohen today filed a motion
in court in New York City to keep stormy
Daniels attorney Michael avenatti out of
the case in the Southern District of New
York Cohen's attorney contends that
avenatti violated rules of the court by
making numerous false statements about
Cohen and by publishing bank records of
Cohen that had quote no lawful source
we'll see what the court says soon right
follow that one John Roberts Lava the
NOAA's lawn John thanks